let's talk about Laura Ingraham she has
a show on Fox News the program has been
repulsive and revolting for a long time
that's not news the most recent time we
talked about Laura Ingraham it was when
she equated child internment camps for
immigrant children to summer camps that
was about I guess it was about a month
or two ago but now it's been taken to a
new level because Ingraham is spouting
straight-up white nationalism in
primetime on fox news I've often talked
about code that's used to bait people
this kind of relates to our conversation
at the top of the show about race
baiting so if you have some political
savvy you don't straight-up say black
and brown people are horrible and are
destroying our country you speak and
double entendre as you say the values we
hold dear are at risk as a result of
immigration from underprivileged parts
of the world right you word it in a way
where you're kind of hiding behind
language you don't say uncontrolled gun
ownership is fine except when it's black
people no you don't say it that way you
say enforcement of gun laws must focus
on low-income populations in urban areas
who are obtaining guns specifically to
commit crimes right or again however you
want to phrase it Laura Ingraham went on
a rant about demographic changes
destroying our country and this is one
of the features of the trump era and I
call it a feature because Trump is like
this it's now more acceptable in the
milieu of the 2018 Trump is to say
straight up a lot of the things you used
to feel some shame about saying and you
would hide behind ambiguity or double
meanings here's Laura Ingraham straight
up saying America no longer exists
because of demographic changes as a
result of both illegal and legal
remember they used to say that legal
immigration is fine legal immigration is
also part of why we've lost America
because in some parts of the country it
does seem like the America that we know
and love doesn't exist anymore massive
demographic changes have been foisted
upon the American people and their
changes that none of us have were voted
for and most of us don't like from
Virginia to California we
see stark examples of how radically in
some ways the country has changed now
much of this is related to both illegal
and in some cases legal immigration that
of course progressives love so they run
b-roll over her shoulder of Hispanics
harvesting food she wouldn't eat if it
weren't for those illegal and legal
immigrants that she claims to be so
concerned about they literally put up
the b-roll that proves why these
individuals are so important to the
United States being the United States of
America listen to what she's saying
America as we know it no longer exists
because of demographic changes brought
on by immigration cut the doublespeak
demographic changes means a lower
percentage of white people due to a
higher percentage of non-white people
when she says because of immigration
that is saying America is no longer what
it once was it's no longer real America
because there's too many brown people
that have come in the people who are
single-handedly supporting her eating
food and assimilating nutrition and
nutrients so that she can remain alive
yeah she says it doesn't seem like the
America we know sounds kind of like an
observation rather than her making a
point if she was to make a point then
she'd have to go into the statistics of
you know the population of white people
declining but she doesn't even want to
get into that you know wants to make it
about feeling and the most important
element of this is the word foisted the
word foisted demographic changes have
been foisted upon America to foist is to
impose something that's unwelcome right
most of the immigration to the US has
been legal in accordance with the laws
of the country when white people came
from Europe and came to what is now the
United States and killed endless Native
Americans that is demographic change
foisted upon a population violently so
people moving to the US like they've
moved to the US since the beginning of
the country is not the violent voice
thing she's trying to frame what she's
saying did happen it just isn't over the
last 20 years because of people coming
from Latin America to work in the
restaurant industry and in the
agriculture industry and of course in
every industry including medicine and
law and everything else it's how the
country was created there was
demographic change for
stood upon the people who were already
in the country and it's called when
white people came here and killed Native
Americans and by the way I mentioned
this she mentions that both illegal and
legal immigrants are part of the problem
I thought Republicans were still
claiming they only are against illegal
immigration I guess she's now including
both of those and I don't know how this
woman has a single sponsor left at this
point she's saying she wants a white
country she's saying the real America is
a white America and we've lost that and
apparently Fox News I guess tacitly is
okay with this one of the top three
cable networks in the country is not
reacting to what she said I guess they
like it yeah and also Laura Ingraham
does have three adopted children from
foreign countries oh one from Russia two
from Russia and one from Guatemala mmm I
wonder how they would feel about this
I'm sure
unfortunately I'm sure that they are
completely brainwashed by Laura Ingraham
if they're even old enough to be I have
no idea about any of these individuals
but you know making the argument that
she couldn't possibly be racist because
she has a Hispanic daughter or son
that's called identity politics and I
thought that they were against that so
I'd be curious to see whether she makes
that argument discuss this with us on
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program sponsored in part by movement
you guys have heard me talk about
movement it's those college dropouts
that started their own watch company
which has grown like crazy they've sold
almost 2 million watches in over 160
countries
I still wear my movement watches every
single day I've got two of them
the watches start at just 95 bucks they
revolutionize fashion and they don't
believe that style should break the bank
I would advise you not to go to one of
those department stores and spend 4 or
500 bucks on a watch that quite frankly
doesn't look that good and looks like
it's out of the 1910s perfectly great
stuff came out of that phase but it's a
little bit outdated at this point check
out the site they've doubled the number
of watch Styles they continue to expand
they've not only introduced new watch
collections for men and women
they've got sunglasses which I used
during my recent road trip on the west
coast they also have
fashion-forward bracelets for her and my
favorite style continues to be the one
that I have which is sort of like the I
guess it's called the coronagraph I
don't know what these things are called
I just know that they look good and one
suggestion to check out also is the
revolver collection which I like 15% is
what you can save today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash Pakman these make great
gifts for yourself or somebody else
check out the expanding collection at
MVM t-dot-com slash Pakman 15 percent
off free shipping free returns